parti de new york le vol 111 devait se
rendre à genève environ une heure après
le décollage l'équipage décèle une odeur
inhabituelle puis de la fumée dans le
poste de pilotage
[Musique]
après avoir signalé son état d'urgence
l'avion est autorisé à atterrir à
l'aéroport international de halifax
mais il ne se rendra jamais 22 ans 31 à
12 km de la côte le vol swissair 111
venait de s'abîmer dans l'océan et ce à
une vitesse de 700 kilomètres heure on
estime que l'accident a provoqué la
désintégration d'avion en plus de 2
millions de pièces
on a ramené à la surface environ un
million de ces pièces qui ont été
acheminés vers un centre de tri un
chiffre en bleu en nouvelle écosse
s'agissait de la plus vaste opération du
genre dans l'histoire canadienne de
l'aviation
selon l' enquête officielle des arcs
électriques aurait provoqué un incendie
des circuits électroniques du réseau
divertissement de bord il ya cinq ans
pendant une enquête de l'émission de
féfé state sur les ondes de notre
service anglophone c'est bien ici a mis
à jour une série d'allégations étonnante
au sujet d'un lien possible entre la
tragédie est un acte terroriste
un lien qui auraient choisi délibérément
de ne pas vérifier les enquêteurs
canadiens
le sergent tom jobim qui était affecté à
lenquête en tant que spécialiste en
incendie criminel affirmait à l'équipe
de l'émission enquête qu'on l'avait
empêché d'approfondir la thèse voulant
qu'un dispositif incendiaire et causé
l'écrasement
il disait avoir détecté des niveaux
élevés de magnésium un ingrédient clé
dans les bombes incendiaires une matière
découverte en concentration dans le
cockpit
d'autre part un métallurgiste james
brown utilisant la spectroscopie
électronique à vis sans fin a des goûts
vers lui aussi les nouveaux suspects de
magnésium dix fois plus prévu et
d'autres éléments associés à des
incendies de câbles font du town
j'oublie déclaré que la grc avait
rapidement rejeté la théorie du
dispositif incendiaire et qu'il avait
été contraint de mettre fin à son
enquête affirment aussi que le
commissaire de la grc lui a
personnellement ordonné de retirer toute
référence au magnésium ou aux soupçons
liés à une bombe de son rapport d'
enquête si le canada ne peut mener une
enquête à terme relativement à 229
potentiel homicide que se produit-il
alors lorsqu'il n'y en a qu'un se
demandait-il malgré plusieurs demandes
en ce sens la grc et le bureau de la
sécurité des transports du canada ont
toujours refusé de commenter les
allégations de tonnes joue pis
reportage de radio canada international